[Music]
hello Wolfgang I've been doing some
reading today I've been looking into
where the missing Avengers could
possibly be and after spending most of
the day on the internet and doing some
thinking of my own I think I have found
the most plausible theories of where
Hawkeye and ant-man and the wasp could
be before we get started please be sure
to subscribe to my channel all you need
is the password what is the password
Ironman sucks thank you I did a video
not too long ago about how Hawkeye will
become Ronin and I still believe that
that is going to happen I I think that's
pretty much a set thing but how does he
get there right that's the question and
I've read not just today but just
overtime a lot of different theories
concerning Hawkeye and Ronin I'm going
to list a few but I'm going to talk
about how I think it will all pan out in
the movie
so of course one theory is that he'll
just retire he retired before Captain
America Civil War and everything kind of
goes bad and then he has to come out of
retirement to help everything
unfortunately I think if they go down
this route of him retiring then his
family will die
Alki becomes Ronin due to a severe
tragedy in his life and a good majority
of the people out there believe that
this will in fact be that tragedy once
his family dies he'll team up with Nick
Fury and agent Maria hill and start to
rebuild shield I then think that at the
end of Avengers infinity war or even
maybe Avengers 4 we will be introduced
to Ronan and then shield will make its
comeback in an attempt to defeat Thanos
so that's one way you could go let's
talk about another way another way they
could take it is that Hawkeye will
actually die then he will be brought
back to life by Wanda or some other form
maybe leavin the time stone and this is
actually how he becomes Ronan in the
comics so it's not a too far-fetched
idea but once he becomes Ronan he will
go on a secret mission to track
something down with nebula that's right
nebula this theory stems from actress
Karen Gilliam who plays nebula it's
comments in an interview that she had it
states that she said nebula will make an
unexpected friend during the film and of
course what could they be searching for
the soul stone
fabula of course wants to kill thanos
because Stannis tortured her as she was
a child so it makes sense that she would
want to track down the soul stone to
make sure Stannis does not get it
himself and it also makes sense that the
Avengers and the guardians of the galaxy
would want an Avenger to go with nebula
as well so they'd most likely want to
spare someone who isn't exactly too
powerful
sorry Hawkeye these are two scenarios
that we very well could see in Avengers
infinity war and Avengers 4 but then
again they are just theories so we'll
have to wait to find out ant-man and the
wasp I've seen some really cool theories
concerning ant-man and the wasp we've
seen some photos of the set of Avengers
4 and it has ant-man Captain America
Iron Man and Hulk in it so we know that
ant-man is gonna play a crucial role in
Avengers 4 but what will he be doing in
Avengers infinity war the wasp is in the
film as well so it's safe to say that
she'll be right next to ant-man
one--there that is fairly popular is
that they will be in the quantum realm
this makes sense because it has been
stated that in the movie they will
explore the quantum realm more than they
did in the first ant-man but what will
they be doing in the quantum realm some
say that they will be looking for
Captain Marvel it's really hard to tell
with the ending of Captain Marvel will
be but it has been theorized that she'll
end up in the quantum realm and that
ant-man and the wasp will be looking for
her to bring her back into present time
this makes sense because Captain Marvel
movie will take place in the 1990s but
it is said that she will appear in
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4 so
it makes sense that Ant Man of the wasp
would be sent to find her or maybe they
find her accidentally and in BAM she's
an infinity war another theory which I
actually really hope happens is that Ant
Man and the wasp will actually be in the
background the whole time Disney has
done this before with the release of
Lion King 1.5 which showed what Timon
and Pumbaa were secretly doing behind
the scenes this theory states that in
ant-man and the wasps they will show
what Ant Man of the wasp were up to you
during infinity war this last theory is
a little weird and raises a lot of
questions but I can see how it makes
sense the theory is that somehow ant-man
and the wasps have gotten their hands on
the soulstone then they shrink it down
and put it inside Captain America I know
it's a little far-fetched and it does
raise a lot of questions
it would explain how Captain America is
able to resist a nose and the trailers
I've got some questions on this one
myself like are ant-man in the wash just
inside Captain America the whole entire
movie does cap didn't even know that
they went inside of him to put the soul
stone in there but most importantly
we've seen in a trailer that Thanos has
the sole stone at one point so if it is
inside of Captain America the Stannis
kill him but will he die in a vendor's
infinity war over Avengers 4 I know it's
a complicated theory but I'd love to
hear your thoughts on it as well as all
the other theories that I stated
previously in this video let me know
your thoughts in the comments below as
well as any other theories that you
might have of your own please be sure to
give this video a thumbs up and please
subscribe to my channel to join the
Wolfgang who I love so much admit you
need me we're connected can you feel
that we're done here
move out the way I'm gonna run you over
thank you so much for watching woof woof
by virtue of this metric trade I know
I'm sure too in person but small
everyone says that but hey if you're
here to arrest me out there's some
people that like to roll along here's
our work small street you tell him where
pepper is and they'll stop doing it